every year you don't know what to expect
I mean people always say is this show
scripted is it scripted it is it does
not matter
oh I don't remember doing that then I'm
never yelling like that and did I really
look like that and did you read it
really say that and why werster denied
arguing you should apologize you're the
only one that wants to talk all the time
it's just always really wild to see it
replay back so you can see highs you can
see lows you see lots of laughing and
lots of crying now you're being listened
to
you're gonna see me dating and you know
dating isn't easy and you just have to
make it fun because what else can you do
you have to keep it chipper attitude I'm
definitely ready to connect with someone
great in my life and behalf as it
happens if it doesn't it doesn't but hey
I'm gonna try he is the nicest man I
have to say we are good friends and
you'll have to see what happens between
him and I have to say he really is a
nice man in a citing app and he's pretty
good on the eyes too
[Music]
you know being with Mario filming with
him it was just kind of deja vu and
y'all just watch what happens you'll
you'll see Mario and I are in a very
good place we're friends we share a
daughter together and listen he was a
really great husband and father for so
many years he really was I mean that's
why we were married for over 20 years if
this is the worst thing
I should get the Medal of Honor you know
Jill and I are friendly and she came in
a few situations that were organically
real and you'll see how she comes in and
out as a guest and of course a new
housewife as well with Barbara she's not
a new housewife I'm sorry oh just a
friend so she's not a new housewife so
so they're just calling heard the new
girl she's I don't know what she is so
very much like her they're not giving
her a nap while they're not getting her
an apple or anything
[Music]